I bought a bunch of air filters
yesterday
um and I got up my water filtration
situation I got a bunch of Life straws
and a big daddy LifeStraw that's like
three gallon take it down to the river
fill it up uh obviously looking at Water
distillation because a few ways to get
vinyl act um what was it Vinyl chloride
vinyl out of your water is distillation
boiling it's not enough I think boiling
it might help because it'll release the
gas a lot of it's just interesting but
um distillation is the key and something
also called a
air air there's a there's an industrial
method to get rid of vinyl acrylate or
vinyl uh chloride I got these names man
I'm not a chemist monochloride is uh
it's like air air blowing or something I
was looking at the uh I was looking at
the collapse of the energy Grid in South
Africa and everything that's going on
there and I started thinking uh I should
buy a generator yeah you should I just
got one totally gonna do that